so yeah on friday i sent the email to
deepmind and on monday morning i came
into work you know opened my emails and
suddenly saw this email from catherine
at deepmind and sure enough there was
these beautiful three-dimensional
structures of every single sequence i'd
sent to catherine and it was just
incredible
plastic is a great material the issue is
how we deal with it at its end of life
and we're really bad at that so we
really need solutions
here we take enzymes from the natural
environment we bring them into our
laboratories here and then we try and
evolve them to do different jobs and the
one we're really focusing on at the
moment is enzymes that can digest
polluting plastics
so we're in the bio recycling laboratory
so we've taken the enzymes that we've
made next door we've brought them into
this laboratory and this equipment here
allows us to add the plastic fragments
to the enzyme we're breaking them down
and recycling them right here in real
time
enzymatic breakdown of plastics is
really low energy it's really
environmentally friendly and it allows
us to recover those building blocks and
infinitely use them over again and that
means we can stop relying on fossil
resources and reduce plastic pollution
the work that we do it's really
essential to understand the protein
structure because the function of an
enzyme is so tightly linked to its
structure so when we know the structure
we can look for more enzymes that maybe
have those shared characteristics
so the holy grail of protein structure
determination has been able to take the
20 amino acid letter code put it into a
program and get the 3d structure back
this is where alpha fold comes in
because that's exactly what it does and
it does it really quickly
previously it took us months years
sometimes impossible to actually get a
structure both alpha fold now we can do
it in literally minutes
so instead of doing one protein at a
time we can now do hundreds or even
thousands at a time
entire phds were made on solving a
single protein structure and now it can
be done in minutes
everybody's reaction around the lab and
especially mine i think we were all
really shocked
we are studying to be these structural
biologists and fixate our careers on
these protein structures
and now a computer program can do that
you know scary at first but actually the
fact that we can work almost
collaboratively with this software it
will actually further our science
it took us quite a long time to go
through this massive database of
structures but opened this whole array
of new three-dimensional shapes we'd
never seen before that could actually
break down plastic there's a complete
paradigm shift we can really accelerate
where we go from here and that really
helps us direct these precious resources
to the stuff that matters and ultimately
reduce plastic pollution
[Music]